on en parlait en début d'émission un
deuxième nano satellite sera mis en
orbite le 9 avril prochain il a été
conçu au l'Atmos au laboratoire
atmosphère et observation spatiale à
Guyancourt et il partira en Californie à
bord du Falcon nine de la société Space
X alors pour en parler avec nous
Mustapha mefta ma première question est
la suivante quel sera la mission de
l'inspire cette seven alors
va avoir plusieurs objectifs donc le
premier c'est d'observer la terre donc
on va s'intéresser aux déséquilibres
énergétique de la planète donc on va
faire des multi-observations depuis
l'espace on va aussi s'intéresser à
l'état de l'ionosphère c'est une des
couches de l'atmosphère qui peut
notamment avoir des impacts sur les
communications on voit aussi en profiter
pour valider des éléments technologiques
pour préparer les futurs missions
spatiales et enfin nous avons aussi à
bord une charge utile qui a été
développée par les radios amateurs alors
lui en cours il y a un club radioamateur
qui s'appelle f6k RK donc c'est aussi
donner la possibilité à des radios
amateurs de pouvoir utiliser l'espace
pour pouvoir communiquer depuis le sol
et qu'est-ce qu'on appelle une charge
utile alors une charge utile c'est comme
pour un véhicule vous avez le véhicule
c'est la plateforme donc sur un site
satellite nous avons la plateforme et la
charge utile ce sont les passagers ou
les bagages donc pour un satellite sont
les instruments qui vont permettre de
faire les mesures et justement c'est une
nano satellite il part pour combien de
temps exactement alors nous nous avons
fait nos calculs pour que la durée de
vie soit de moins 4 années donc
logiquement nous sommes partis pour 4
ans de bonheur et comment ça fonctionne
exactement alors on peut le voir à
l'écran est-ce que de quoi est-ce que ce
composent cet instrument ce satellite ou
l'instrument alors le satellite se
compose de plusieurs instruments
j'imagine alors comme vous pouvez le
voir sur la vidéo sur l'image donc le
satellite est constitué de plusieurs
instruments donc il y a plusieurs
détecteurs qui sont miniaturisés et
c'est détecteurs miniaturisé vont
permettre justement de répondre aux
questions énoncées précédemment
typiquement on voit les petits carrés
blancs qui correspondent à détecteur de
flux à partir de ces éléments nous
pouvons mesurer ce qui est émis par la
planète et la transmission de la
communication entre la Terre et entre le
nanousatellite et la terre elle le se
fait assez rapidement alors on doit
passer par ces petites antennes que l'on
voit aussi au niveau du satellite donc
le satellite va émettre un signal audio
et au sol avec un réseau d'antenne au
sol nous allons récupérer les
informations et justement ce lancement
se fait dans le cadre de la mission
transporteur seven de la société SpaceX
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus alors
SpaceX propose une solution c'est aussi
le cas d'Arianespace nous aurions
préféré partir avec Arianespace
évidemment mais au vu du calendrier nous
avons choisi SpaceX donc transporter 7
c'est pour embarquer plusieurs petits
satellites donc logiquement une centaine
de satellites vont être à bord de ce
lanceur et vont être déployés à une
altitude d'environ 500 km sur une orbite
polaire
et vous aviez dit plusieurs satellites
là on est en phase de nous un anneau
satellite c'est ce que vous pouvez aussi
nous expliquer nous décrire qu'est-ce
que c'est exactement un anneau satellite
alors un anneau satellite c'est comme un
satellite classique sauf qu'on leur
utilise le mot nano parce qu'il est plus
petit donc nous avons les mêmes
fonctions à l'extérieur nous voyons les
cellules solaires qui permettent
d'absorber donc le rayonnement solaire
pour pouvoir apporter l'énergie
électrique pour alimenter l'ensemble du
satellite donc nous allons avoir aussi
des batteries un ordinateur de bord pour
faire la communication avec le les
autres cartes électroniques une carte de
radiocommunication et les détecteurs
eux-mêmes donc nous sommes sur un
satellite classique sauf que la
l'échelle l'échelle est miniaturisée et
combien de temps ce que vous avez mis à
le concevoir son anneau satellite quels
ont été les grandes étapes alors nous
avons mis deux années donc les grandes
étapes c'est d'abord développer l'idée
donc partir d'une idée scientifique dans
nos thématiques de recherche ensuite
c'est faire sa conception donc c'est
pour cela que nous avons l'aide de
plusieurs étudiants notamment de
l'ESTACA
et ensuite une fois que nous avons fait
sa définition nous allons le fabriquer
et ensuite après avoir fabriqué ce
satellite nous allons le tester donc à
Guyancourt nous avons une plateforme de
test qui s'appelle la Pitt la plateforme
de test de Guyancourt nous faisons tous
les essais pour vérifier que le
satellite va bien
respecter les niveaux qu'il verra lors
du lancement lui-même mais aussi les
effets de température en orbite voilà
donc aujourd'hui nous sommes à la
dernière étape le satellite est intégré
sous la coiffe
bientôt nous allons voir le lanceur qui
doit il va s'élever et donc nous allons
avoir un lancement qui est prévu le 9
avril 2023 et justement vous l'aviez dit
tout à l'heure c'est un projet à viser
scientifique mais c'est aussi un projet
avec des étudiants ce que vous pouvez
revenir un peu plus en détail dessus
comment ça s'est déroulé alors c'est
aussi un projet qui a trois composantes
donc la première c'est la partie
recherche associée à nos thématiques le
deuxième aspect c'est la validation
technologique d'éléments en orbite et
enfin la composante pédagogique alors
l'idée c'est de développer ces
instruments et ses satellites aussi avec
les étudiants parce que on peut les
préparer au métier futur et quand on
développe un satellite nous avons tous
les métiers tous les métiers de
l'ingénieur qui sont qui sont utilisés
oui je voulais savoir quelle est la
différence avec UVSQ sat qui est parti
il y a quelques années quelle est la
différence alors
uvsq-7 a été mis en orbite le 24 janvier
2021 donc après deux ans nous
développons ce satellite déjà le volume
nous avons un satellite qui est deux
fois plus gros ensuite nous avons aussi
acquis de l'expérience car ce satellite
uvsqat nous a permis de mieux comprendre
certaines mesures observées donc nous
avons amélioré la performance du
satellite donc un effet incrémental et
enfin comme nous avons un satellite qui
est plus gros nous avons intégré de
nouvelles missions scientifique
qu'est-ce que ça vous fait à vous de
voir votre nano-satellite bientôt partir
qu'est-ce que ça vous fait
personnellement c'est toujours quelque
part bon c'est une fierté pour le
laboratoire et pour les équipes qui ont
développé ce programme parce qu'il y a
aussi beaucoup d'équipes derrière nous
qui font ce programme et ensuite c'est
beaucoup beaucoup d'émotions parce que
il y a beaucoup beaucoup d'heures de
travail et donc nous attendons avec
impatience le lendemain d'heures de
travail sur ce projet alors en général
on raisonne plutôt en équivalent temps
plein personne il faut considérer au
moins une dizaine de personnes
par an pendant au moins deux années
et justement pour revenir sur l'uvsq7
quel bilan est-ce que vous en faites
aujourd'hui vous en êtes satisfait alors
complètement satisfait parce que uvsq-7
ça durée de vie initiale c'était une
année et là ça fait plus de 2 ans qu'il
est en orbite donc il est toujours
opérationnel donc vis-à-vis de sa durée
de vie c'est excellent et ensuite
vis-à-vis des résultats que nous avons
c'est aussi très bien parce que nous
avons déjà accumulé plus de 10 millions
de données donc nous arrivons à suivre
l'évolution des variables climatiques
qui nous intéressent avec une basse
résolution parce que on ne va pas faire
mieux avec un petit satellite que avec
un gros satellite par contre l'intérêt
de ces petits satellites c'est de les
utiliser en grappe d'en avoir plusieurs
donc l'idée avec ce deuxième satellite
c'est d'avoir deux points de mesure et
cela va nous permettre de diviser par
deux le temps de revisite parce qu'un
des paramètres qui est fondamental c'est
de pouvoir réobserver une scène avec une
fréquence plus plus importante et aussi
ce que vous avez prévu de partir en
Californie pour le lancement
non parce que c'est sur une base
militaire donc j'avais évidemment une
place pour assister au lancement parce
qu'il y a toujours des places
particulières mais non parce que je vais
pas aller tout seul là-bas et de pour
des raisons aussi écologiques si vous
voulez
sans problème pour le prochain lancement
et le prochain satellite avec un
lancement prévu en 2025 j'espère ce
matin on a aussi appris une
action alignée depuis
observer honnêtement alors avec d'autres
instruments oui c'est possible mais un
satellite qui est en orbite basse lui se
focaliserait essentiellement sur la
planète Terre mais aussi le soleil donc
oui nous pouvons mais pas avec un
satellite
et vous avez également publié donc ce
livre l'espace et le new space au
service du climat qui est sorti cette
année c'est vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus là-dessus alors oui je peux
vous en dire là l'idée c'est de
présenter un peu la situation vis-à-vis
de la conquête spatiale donc depuis
quelques années nous avons basculé dans
une nouvelle ère certains appellent cela
le new space d'autres le Next space donc
j'essaie de décrire ce phénomène et
enfin au travers du livre je vais te
montrer l'importance de l'observation de
la Terre notamment avec des satellites
pour avoir un meilleur état de la
situation notamment vis-à-vis du
réchauffement climatique donc l'idée
c'est d'utiliser les satellites comme
vigie du climat pour pouvoir répondre
aux enjeux environnementaux et
écologiques qui sont à des enjeux
majeurs du 21e siècle et bien merci
Mustapha mefta d'être venu en plateau
pour en parler avec nous je le rappelle
vous êtes chercheur olattmos laboratoire
qui a conçu le Nano satellite inspire 7
seven kit décollera ou qui sera mis en
orbite le 9 avril prochain